what's going on guys in this video i
thought i'd give my take on yuno facing
off against xenon
in black clover episode 161. as a manga
reader i've been anticipating this
moment for the longest time
especially as xenon is my personal
favorite member of the dark triad
i'll be explaining the real reason why
yuno lost so easily
and a few other things about this
episode worth talking about like why
vandans is being targeted
there won't be any manga spoilers in
this video so no need to worry about
that
and of course you know hit that sub
button if you want to see more videos
like this
okay so in the last episode we saw how
the golden dawn hq
was raided by three people from the
spade kingdom with the leader of the
group being xenon himself
as a member of the dark triad xenon is
possessed by a devil
and therefore he's able to tap into two
different types of magic
he can firstly use bone magic which is
what he was born with
and secondly he can use spatial magic
that belongs to his devil
his spatial magic was already displayed
in episode 160
when xenon was just standing there for
one second and then literally
disappeared during this attack
even one of the members of the golden
dawn was totally confused as to where he
went
with these two magic types he was able
to single-handedly defeat the diamond
kingdom's strongest soldiers before the
timeskip
and now in the present day he's coming
for the captain of the golden dawn
the two dark disciples who were with him
are not possessed by a devil
but instead they have been given devil
powers by the dark triad
and this just kind of like boosts their
original magic but it doesn't mean they
have two magic types
as one of the dark disciples stated
william vanjins is an arcane stage mage
which means his magic is an irregular
type that has potential to defeat a
devil
aster's anti-magic and yami's dark magic
are other examples of arcane stage
abilities
and the reason william is being targeted
is because he has this power
the dark triad have a specific plan in
mind and so they're not just you know
they're not
randomly targeting every arcane stage
mage in the world
they're specifically going for vengeance
and his world tree magic
anyway after yuno defeated the first
dart disciple and klaus landed the
finishing blow on the second dart
disciple
there was still one person left they had
to face xenon had been terrorizing
captain vargan since the previous
episode
and used a bone magic spell called
eternal fangs which is what caused the
ceiling to cave in
if you look at this shot you can see
that william did fight back as there are
tree branches pretty much everywhere
but it was likely too hard for him to
fight whilst also trying to protect alex
dora that's why william was destroyed so
quickly
i mean i think xenon would have beaten
william regardless of what happened but
it helped xenon that vangers wasn't
fully focused on the battle itself
when yuno and the gang confront xenon i
absolutely love this because you can see
that he just
expects nothing from them and in his
defense you know klaus
and the compass girl did get destroyed
pretty quickly
going into this episode i was a tiny bit
nervous on how they'd animate this scene
because when you look at the manga panel
it was so chaotic and just
so much going on i was a bit worried but
no as you can see it looks fine
and they did justice to xenon's giant
bones moving on to the thing that the
anime did better than the manga
this was when yuno assumed that his
squad mates were still okay
and his realization that they've been
massacred was way more impactful in
animated form
the voice acting was also 10 out of 10
like whoever you know's japanese voice
actor is i don't know their name
they are just fantastic even from the
last episode when
when yuno arrived at the hq and he kind
of like gasped everything about it was
just fantastic so
i really highly rate that voice actor
now one of the many reasons why you know
lost his fight
was that he had already faced off
against two dart disciples at this point
and the damage he took from that first
battle is what held him back
the second dart disciple even spells it
out for us when he says that yuna looks
tired
so basically what this is trying to
convey is that
xenon did not fight a full strength uno
on the flip side
yuno did fight against a full strength
xenon who i mean
this character did not even take his
hands out his pockets until he went in
for the kill
so right there it's not a fair matchup
you have a full strength character
against a weakened character
not to mention the full strength
character also has the power of a devil
on his side
when xenon's devil is activated the
anime doesn't fully explain what's going
on here and i won't go into spoilers or
anything
but at the very least you can clearly
see that the devil's spatial magic has
created a
cube that surrounds both characters
whilst they were in this space
xenon was able to do something that made
my draw drop when i first read it
and uh you know seeing it animated i
loved it as well and this was when he
cut through the spirit of zephyr
i had never even considered the
possibility that it could be cut
especially not with a
a random sword made of bone but you know
a reason this
might have happened is due to the space
that xenon trapped them in
later in the episode after yuno was
stabbed through the stomach
the fact that silth was starting to
disappear is proof that he was really
going to die here
you could argue that maybe xenon could
have done a more efficient job in trying
to kill him
but remember that from xenon's
perspective everyone in the golden dawn
was already dead at this point from his
point of view so there would be no one
around who could actually come and save
yuno in time
anyway guys let me know in the comments
what you thought of black clover episode
and which member of the golden dawn are
you gonna miss the most
out of all the ones that died the only
one i really cared about even a little
bit
was uh this guy i don't even know i
think his name's hamon
yeah he was funny in that tournament arc
they had um so he's the one i really
just
i don't even care that much but you know
a little bit i care a little bit
until the next one peace out